[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Joseph is
in Chicago Joseph what's going
on hey guys thanks for taking my call um
I just have a question on my student
loans so I have about 58,000 in student
loans it's had a really low interest
rate
2.6% um and I'm set to pay it off uh by
August 2026 my monthly payment is about
19900 I also have a home loan of 380 at
6% and I'm just wondering if I should
just bite the bullet and pay off the
rest of my student loans I've already
paid off about a 100 so I have about
100,000 in cash also I have 160 in
401K um but I'm just wondering if I
should do that or keep it in the market
earning five s% half of it's in a high
interest savings so I'm earning 5% there
um it's just that low interest rates
really I would pay them off before the
day is
over really and here's why I tell you
that that's not just me making up advice
because that's exactly what I
did I cannot tell you dude the the so
tax on your amydala is worth more than
the
2.1% extra money you're earning in this
little weird snapshot in history in a
high yield savings account over the
interest rate you have on these
loans every time every time a stock
ticker Rolls by that has something about
forgiveness or for this you look up your
heart rate increases your body fills up
with cortisol in Adrenaline cuz that's
that involves
you I literally did not look up other
than to hear from hurting people about
the Biden forgiveness plan because I
paid him
off just didn't I mean just didn't
didn't
care and that's worth any percentage of
money that I could have earned in a high
yield savings account
period yeah I think that's I mean that's
kind of the path I've been leaning
towards it's it's just uh by the end of
the day paid
off all right I think that's probably
the best advice have you done the math
on what you would actually
earn um it'd be about like an extra
maybe 5,000 a
year well you're making five you said
you have 100,000 in cash and savings
making 5%
right yeah I got 65 in a uh brokerage
account and then I got 35 you have way
too much money to still be having debt
around your neck it just doesn't make
sense you're too successful and you're
too smart what is your what is your
degree
in I have a law degree I'm an attorney
yeah how much do you
make um 300 maybe 330 with
bonus why do you have why do you have
student Lo
man well I mean it was 165 so I've
already paid off 110 like August 2026
sounds like an eternity away like I
don't even know bro hey I'm gonna be
listen I was a Dena students at a law
school for years okay so I I get
it choose to be free for the first time
in your life
man owe nobody
anything and then if you decide to
reduce your billables hours by X or your
partner says hey we're going to need you
to do this before we consider you can go
I'm not doing that because I don't owe
anybody anything here's a fun exercise
Joseph go make an every dollar budget
where there's no debt in the picture and
you make
$380,000 and then tell me that you would
go back in time and go yeah I'll take
the debt at a low interest rate for fun
man if I'm in your shoes I'm going to
use this incred in income and this
incredible you know stockpile of cash
that you have and go I'm going to pay
off these student loans I'm going to
start attacking the house and I'm going
to be a baby steps millionaire no time
and you should be making 380 instead of
hanging on to debt for the next three
four five years because of a low
interest rate hey you know why you know
who makes you go to work tomorrow the
government because you owe them what a
sucker dude pay pay them off today you
have
$100,000 in cash you could be debt free
day right except for your
house yeah that's right give me the
final number you about 55 left on them
is that right 58 yeah I mean I guess my
only thing is if I have a 100,000
earning five six perent over the next
three years I'll earn 15,000 and
interest and you know you make
$380,000 I mean the five grand a year is
not changing your life it's fun money
okay do this that's true don't go to a
bar for six months there's your $5,000
it's also true or get one of those suits
just don't replace it that's your
$5,000 yeah dude my dissertation was on
the mental health of attorneys I
know I know and here's what I'm telling
you choose Freedom over being right
choose Freedom over
2.1% difference
between um what you owe the government
versus what you're making in a high
yield account right
now choose peace because you go to war
every day that's what you do for for
guys like me I call you and say help and
you go I will I got you and so the
greatest gift you can give yourself when
you are a Hired Hand when you are
somebody who all you do all day is go to
battle for other people the greatest
gift you can give yourself is a good
night's sleep is peace in your house and
when you owe money to the government and
they're telling you no you're going to
get get these 2200 billable hours
because you owe us you owe me bro take
just take that off the table I'd be debt
free before the afternoon is over and by
the way you'll still have $40,000 in the
account Cry Me a River with $100 bills
Joseph you're good I'm proud of you man
congratulations i' I've seen people post
this they go I have a mortgage at
2.75% I'm going to stay in this house
forever and I go golly you've locked
yourself in a prison over an interest
rate exactly you have changed yourself
so if you want to move you're like no
because then we have to take on a bigger
interest rate I can't move I'm stuck
what kind of Life have you built for
yourself when you don't have options be
free choose Freedom just be free forget
interest rate freedom I know goodness
gracious it's available to you but it's
starts with going it's more than math
I'm solving for Freedom here that part
is a partial math equation but it takes
some getting out of your own head and
getting out of your own way and going we
could have all of our income back that's
our greatest way we building tool why
are we giving it to lenders thinking
that we're winning that's not how it
works